steve scully the political editor of
c-span
and the man who was supposed to moderate
the second presidential debate was
caught chatting with a very anti-trump
voice over the weekend on twitter he was
tweeting with anthony scaramucci he
thought this was supposed to be private
he sent out this tweet he said
scaramucci should i respond to trump now
this was clearly intended to be
a private message and yet it went out
publicly the way that twitter used to
work
it was a little confusing how to do each
of those things now obviously they're
they're
much different so what does scully say
he says
he was hacked this is the line steve
scully notified us that his twitter
account was hacked according to
the commission on presidential debates
cpd
the commission on presidential debates
reported the apparent hack to the fbi
and twitter and we understand the
federal authorities are looking into the
issue
there is a hack here all right there are
hacks
all around us as a matter of fact and
one thing they have in common
is all these hacks are trying to take
down donald trump i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from last thursday was
brandon brandon who said i suppose this
is with regard to that video
of chris rock and mark ruffalo and
all of these other celebrities getting
naked and telling you to vote for biden
he says this is not what i meant when i
said to expose the liberals
fair enough absolutely fair enough
scaramucci himself tried to bail out mr
scully he said i accept steve scully at
his word let's not cancel any more
people from our culture
for absolutely something like this it's
insignificant he's an objective
journalist
but he's not an objective journalist he
is actually a former joe biden
employee steve scully worked for joe
biden as an intern
he then worked for ted kennedy he's a
liberal
he's a left winger and now he i guess
he's been a journalist for some time
but so many of these journalists are
very far
on the left and that's just the way it
is the committee
on debates wants a virtual debate now
because president trump had coronavirus
however
long ago and president trump is saying
no way to this he cannot do a virtual
debate a virtual debate gives the left
all of the power gives them everything
allows them to mute him allows them to
cut his feet and so he absolutely cannot
do that
bob dole bob dole who was the republican
presidential nominee in 1996
he was the first candidate that i ever
supported in my first grade classroom i
was campaigning for bob dole
all i knew about the race was that bob
dole was a war hero and bill clinton was
a draft dodger
i begged my mother who wanted to vote
for clinton i begged her to vote for bob
dole and she finally relented she
thought it was so funny that this
six-year-old young republican
was begging her to vote for bob dole she
let me into the voting booth i pulled
the lever for bob dole
i guess that might have violated some
kind of rule wasn't i was six years old
and pulling
the lever in any case lots of hacks
trying to
rig up this election including the
commission on presidential debates bob
dole said
he knows all the republicans on the
committee and
none of them support trump even the
republicans don't support trump right
this is this is not really a bipartisan
commission
there are squishy liberal republicans
and there are
liberal democrats but there's no nobody
on the trump side of things and this is
why whatever you think of trump i'm not
trying to
say that trump is the greatest
politician ever to live and he's the
most conservative guy that's not quite
what i'm saying
i'm just pointing out that it's at this
point basically trump against the world
whatever you think of trump trump is not
a hack
trump is saying something that is
different that is breaking the two-party
consensus
that that makes it seem like there are
two parties but really they both support
open borders they both support wide
widespread immigration they both support
free trade regimes that give away a lot
of our national sovereignty right they
both support those they both support the
rise of china
and and trump has come in and
changed that up a little bit so whatever
you think of the guy he's not
a hack he's in some ways he's an agent
of chaos
whereas there are plenty of squishy
republicans and then the entire
democratic establishment
those are hacks i mean those are people
who are going to tell you things that
are brazen lies
and they're going to tell it to you with
just absolute
cynicism because they don't respect you
the voter they don't
voters of any stripes a great example of
this is this court packing issue
joe biden has been dodging this issue
and a lot of left-wingers have openly
said we are going to pack
the supreme court we're going to add
justices to the supreme court and stack
it with democrats so we can get our way
and joe biden hasn't answered on that
question so
the other day he was asked it again and
he said not only is he not going to
answer but the voters don't deserve
an answer sir i've got to ask you about
packing the courts and i know that sure
you said yesterday you aren't going to
answer the question until after the
election
but this is the number one thing that
i've been asked about from viewers uh in
the past couple of days well
you've been asked by the viewers who are
probably republicans who don't want me
continuing to talk about what they're
doing to the court right now
well sir don't the voters deserve to
know no i'm not going to play his game
they don't deserve to no shoot i wasn't
supposed to say that part out loud i
mean
i'm not yeah i'm not gonna play trump's
game what is trump's game trump's game
is when even some of the mainstream
media
are asking you what you're going to do
about an extraordinarily consequential
issue
something that hasn't been tried in a
hundred years
a little under 100 years since fdr tried
to pack the court and that was shot down
by public opinion it was shot down by
congress
no i'm not going to play trump's game
it's not trump's game
are you going to pack the court or are
you going to try to
grab an incredible amount of power from
the other branch of government
by stacking your partisans into that
branch of government
so that they more easily acquiesce to
what you want to do
it's an important question biden won't
give an answer he's been he's been
refusing to give an answer on this
now for a month so because biden's
answer is insufficient because even some
of the mainstream media are trying to
get
an answer out of this the democrats have
a new plan which is something that they
have done
for decades now this is what how they
have used political correctness
as one of their most effective political
tools they're just
redefining the term court packing
they're they're they're looking at this
situation and realizing that it's not
advantageous to them so they're going to
redefine
the game it's much like when you would
go to an auto parts store in the brick
and mortar that's not working for you so
you have to redefine the game
by going online which you can do when
you go to rockauto.com rockauto.com
is a family business serving auto parts
customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts does that make any
sense no
go to rockauto.com the catalog is unique
and the best part of all you know me i
don't know anything about cars i don't
know
how to put the doodad on the gizmo
machine or whatever
the rockauto.com catalog is so simple
even i can navigate you can quickly
choose the parts available for your
vehicle
choose the brand specifications prices
you prefer reliably low prices
for the pros and for do-it-yourselfers
and for the do-it-yourselfers who then
have pros come
work on their car that is what you get
at rockauto.com go there right now
to see all the parts available for your
car or truck and then
most importantly write knowledge canada
w-l-e-s in their how did you hear about
us box
so that they know that we sent you
what's that address
rockauto.com
democrats are now attempting with a
straight face
to redefine the phrase court packing so
court packing
is when you you've got the judiciary and
then you
add judges you add seats to the
judiciary so right now
for instance we have nine judges on the
supreme court now
if amy barrett actually makes it to the
court
then you've got a 6-3 conservative
majority
really it's a 5-4 though because john
roberts is a squish but fine call it
5-4-6-3
it's a conservative court well if you
add three democrats to the court
now it's a six-six court
right because those three democrats are
going to be added under a democratic
administration the democrat judges tend
to be much more partisan anyway
so you've got six six what if you had
five judges to the court
gosh that's pretty good now you've got a
left wing court that's what court
packing is
fdr tried to do it in 1937 because the
supreme court kept striking down the
unconstitutional parts of his new deal
program
and he tried to pack it and the public
opinion was never for it
he could never convince the american
people to do it congress never even took
it up
and it fizzled out and died well now the
left is
trying to revive it dick durbin second
most powerful democrat in the senate
goes on chuck todd's show on nbc and
insists that actually it's republicans
who have been packing the court
i can tell you that we're getting this
question it's a common question being
asked because
american people have watched the
republicans pack in the court over the
last three and a half years and they
brag about it
they've taken every vacancy and filled
it did you know that they've sent
us and we have approved only with their
votes i might add
10 people who have been judged
unanimously
unqualified by the american bar
association do you know how many
judicial nominees came from obama who
were judged
unanimously unqualified none so we are
dealing with people on the court packed
into the court with
little or no qualification who are going
to be there for a long time so it's
understandable
the republicans raised the issue of
court packing did i mention chuck it's
republicans who are court packing
no it isn't of course it isn't there is
obviously a difference
between adding judges to a court
so that increasing the number of the
judges so that you can stack it with
your partisans
and filling the open judge seats
as is not only your constitutional right
but the constitutional requirement
when there are nine seats on a court and
the judge dies and you fill it as the
constitution tells you to that's
obviously very different
than completely rewriting the judiciary
adding seats
so that you can cram through your
legislation that otherwise wouldn't get
through
obviously very different things but
obviously the talking point went out
and democrats are pursuing this hakeem
jeffries who's the house democrat caucus
chairman
tweets out stop asking dems about
packing the court we aren't doing it
they are meaning republicans in order to
take away our health care they're
packing the court governor steve bullock
of montana i think he's of montana isn't
he remember he ran for president for
about five seconds
he said four years ago you said no we
should never confirm a justice when
people are voting
let the people decide and now that's the
most important thing to you you are
packing the court right now
okay sheldon whitehouse a senator from
rhode island
he tweets out it's time democrats
started looking behind the curtain of
the republican special interest court
packing scheme
they've been at it for years we've been
asleep at the wheel all of this reeks
of a particularly sad kind of hackery
because they're they're they clearly got
together in a room and they said gosh
guys we can't keep evading the court
pack in question forever
we've been evading it now for over a
month at least
what do we do and one of them said i
know what we'll do
you know we'll do we'll we'll say that
it's them who's court packing like nuh
uh you
you know like when you're in third grade
and someone calls you saying you say no
uh you
you i am rubber and you are glue or
something like that that's what we're
going to say about court packing and
their basis for this here's their
dastardly evidence that they
dug up from one of sean hannity's shows
they put out there is
when mitch mcconnell bragged about how
he
as the senate majority leader was
holding up some of obama's judicial
nominees
so i was shocked that uh former
president obama left so many vacancies
and didn't try to fill those positions
i'll tell you why i was in charge of the
of what we did the last two years of the
obama administration i give
i and i will give you full credit for
that and by the way take a bow all right
that was a good life
um i'll tell you why because i
said to uh say hello to my little
friend then he leans down and just takes
a big big face full of that
cocaine constitutionality constitutional
cocaine mitch
said that as senate majority leader
barack obama has the right to nominate
the judges and then i a senate majority
leader
can take them up to advise and consent
and then either i consent or we reject
and then they go through
so this is a the perfectly ordinary
operation of government
especially when there's divided power
right the voters sent obama
and the democrats to the white house
they sent mitch mcconnell and the
republicans
to run the senate and so there's going
to be friction that's the way the system
is supposed to operate operating within
that constitutional system and within
the traditional norms of our republic
is a very different thing than
trying to subvert the judiciary itself
by adding seats to the court but michael
the the constitution doesn't say how
many judges need to be on the court
that's true
but the judges have been set for a very
long time well over a hundred years
nobody has tried to change the number of
judges since fdr who failed at it
because people didn't want it because
they found it to be
subversive of the constitution
we've got a number here and what
democrats are trying to do is throw a
grenade in there because they can't win
this is what the left always does
the left is a stickler for the rules
until the rules don't work for them
and then the rules don't matter they
completely undermine them
and republicans and conservatives often
get stuck in this bad position where we
think that if we just play by the rules
if we try to use their own logic against
them then they'll come around and
they'll see the light
they won't they won't and we we just
we keep thinking no guys you we're we're
reasonable we're willing to work for you
you said you for instance this is a
great example of this from the 60s and
70s
you said you were the free speech
supporters remember you liberals
you led the free speech movement at
berkeley but now
you're opposing free speech isn't that
hypocritical
they don't care they don't care the
whole point of this
was just to subvert the traditional
standards
wait a second guys you said
that you support feminism but now you
support gender ideology which undermines
feminism isn't that hypocritical they
don't care they don't care
they are just trying to subvert the
traditional american standards
whatever way they want to do that
whatever way is effective they will do
that
wait a second guys you've been accusing
trump of exceeding the bounds of the
constitution but now you're trying to do
that on the go
they don't care stop stop trying to make
the argument from hypocrisy
it it doesn't bother them there are a
handful of liberals left
who want to maintain the veneer at least
of consistency and constitutionality one
of them
is a guy who falls into political
hackery a whole lot
jake tapper on cnn we were pointing out
some of his hackery last week
but sometimes i think he still wants to
view himself
as the last honest man in the room the
journalist she's a liberal maybe but
he's a straight shooting liberal and and
so
jake tapper called out this hackery
about court packing and a biden
spokesman on cnn
she had no answer but she didn't care he
said it's not constitutional
what they're doing how is it not
constitutional what they're doing
his point is that the people have an
opportunity to weigh in on this
constitutional process through
their vote and we are now in the midst
of the election
millions of people have already cast
their votes and you see that the vast
majority of people say that they
want the person who wins the election on
november 3rd
to nominate the justice that's a poll
that's not the constitution
by by trying to by trying to that's that
is their con
there's the constitutional process of
advising consent the american people get
to have their say
by voting for president by voting for
senators
we are now 23 days from the election but
it's not unconstitutional
millions of millions of votes millions
of votes they're being
voters are being denied their
constitutional right to have a say in
this process
they're trying to ram through are trying
to ram through
a a nominee who by the way is going to
change the makeup of the court
and we see time and time again poll
after poll shows that most americans
vehemently disagree with this again okay
that's the whole vote should happen on
november 3rd that's not what the word
constitution
means so jake's ever good on him because
he's calling out this
crazy bs but this biden spokesman this
woman
doesn't care you see she's she's
fairly unflappable she just keeps
talking she goes
it's the court and the railroading and
the change the makeup of the court and
she's just saying words
the words are not responding to the
points that jake tapper is making
the words are not even making an
argument what the words amount to
is it is our interest to have
a leftist judiciary and so we're going
to do that
and between these two styles here jake
tapper is
sort of at least his pretense that the
argument has to make sense at least at a
superficial level
and this biden spokesman who says it
doesn't matter we don't need to make any
arguments it's all about interest
between those two visions of american
politics
i think it's the latter that's winning
right now i don't think we're making
particularly strong arguments or having
particularly robust debate
just look at the debate between
president trump and joe biden two weeks
ago
to see that it's just people talking
over one another
this is a consequence if you want to
trace it back all the way to the very
very beginning this is a consequence
of the left essentially denying
objective reality
when the left says for instance a man
can be a woman or there's no such thing
as the truth there's just your truth and
my truth and
you can't use your faculties of reason
to have an opinion because you're a
straight white male
you can't deny my lived experience the
left constantly pushing all of these
hoaxes and and division the effect of
that downstream is
you can't have a debate one side is
going to say but the constitution and
then the other side
is going to say okay hey i got your
constitution right here
and that's what the election is coming
down to now perhaps
we're still at a point in this country
where there's a sliver sliver of people
in the middle
for whom coherent arguments matter
but i'm i'm not convinced that we're
there joe biden certainly doesn't think
that we're there that's why joe biden is
embracing
this definition of court packing too and
this is very dangerous
okay it's very very dangerous when
you're in a situation
where logic doesn't matter in politics
you know but look it's a dangerous world
out there that's why you might have a
firearm to protect yourself
from the bad guys who want to do you
physical violence and if you do have a
handgun then you're going to want to
make sure that you have a great holster
okay if you don't have a great holster
you're not doing gun ownership right
starting at just 39 we the people
holsters
are custom designed to fit your firearm
perfectly they're made right here
in the usa they have thousands of
options to choose from plus an amazing
selection of printed holsters their
proprietary clip design allows for you
to easily adjust
both the cant and ride of your holster
so that it will fit comfortably and
securely
at all times now is the time more than
ever to support
american companies i love these guys
they make excellent designs they make an
extremely high quality product they make
it here
in the united states and one of my
favorite parts of this is
it's unbelievably inexpensive go to we
the peopleholsters.com
knowles can wles to get yours every
holster ships free
comes with a lifetime guarantee and you
get an additional 10
off with the code knowles satisfaction
guarantees that brings it from 39
all the way down to 29 which is a very
very good deal
perf if it's not the perfect fit by the
way you can send it back for a total
refund go to we the people holsters dot
com slash knowles
we the peopleholsters.com slash knowles
can wlas offer code
knowles easy to remember it's a
dangerous world so you've got the
the physical danger but you've also got
political dangers dangers to the
political system and that is what
happens
when people are hacks this is this is
what i don't like about hackery and
we can go we can go and criticize any
one thing that trump has done
any particular day or one policy that
he's pushing i'm happy to do it and i've
done it plenty of times
but on this issue of hackery trump ain't
it
he he is like the opposite of a hack he
is saying things
that are that seem deeply unpopular that
require
a fair amount of courage that could have
and by all accounts should have
destroyed his political career many
times
and he hasn't done it you can't say the
same for joe biden joe biden now
now that the democrats have tested out
this court packing line
he himself has decided to adopt it that
following the constitution and
undermining the constitution are
actually the same thing look
the only court packing going on right
now
is going on with republicans attacking
the court now
it's not constitutional what they're
doing we should be focused on what's
happening
right now and the fact is that the only
packing going on
is this court is being packed now by the
republicans
after the vote has already begun i'm
going to stay focused on it so we don't
take the eyes off the ball here
what they're doing is not constitutional
what do you mean it's not constitutional
they this the constitution says the
presidential nominated judge and the
senate will advise and consent that's
exactly what they're doing it's not
that's not even an opt it's not like
well you have this option
constitutionally there's a requirement
that the president nominate a judge
and the judge is going through but he's
just saying words right
that's not it's not constitutional it's
just like during the debate when
president trump said law enforcement
doesn't support biden he goes that's not
true man that's a lie
and and trump gave okay name one
organization in law enforcement that
supports you
biden said uh uh he didn't have an
answer he just said he just goes it's
not constitutional
it's it's wrong it's come on man
come on man so now he's saying we're
we the democrats are going to add these
judges
to the court now did you hear there was
a cough in there
here he goes yeah we meant there was a
physical
hacking up there was a hacking up that
happened and it wasn't just
when he was talking about the judges he
was giving another campaign event in
nevada
and biden had his mask on he had the
mask on for some reason but it was below
his nose
so it was not doing any there was no
scientific or medical argument for the
way he was wearing the mask
but he had it on just as a just as a
political symbol because that's all it
is
the mask is the the political yard sign
of 2020.
the way joe biden is wearing that mask
offers absolutely no protection
against the virus either for himself or
for other people it's just there
as a symbol of his view of politics that
basically we should be led by
bureaucrats and experts
but then it gets even better because not
only is the mask down below his nose
but he has to cough so what does he do
when he has to cough
he pulls down the mask coughs into his
hand
he's there he pulls an investment right
into his right hand
then he puts the mask back up he
actually puts the mask up over his nose
after he coughs all over his hand
he's probably gonna go shake a lot of
hands after that
more evidence more evidence that the way
that this virus
is being treated is not primarily
focused on science
or medicine it's focused on politics
actually now we can defer to the world
health organization which is
don't forget a public health
organization meaning
politics and health public means
politics
so it's got a political aspect too and
obviously
they've been infiltrated largely by
china and they were carrying water for
china and helping china cover up the
illness early on
the world health organization though now
is coming out pretty strongly against
the primary method of combating this
virus namely
the lockdowns you you have people at the
world health organization coming out and
saying
we need to not only
focus on other treatments we actively
need to stop
the lockdowns the lockdowns are hurting
everybody we in the world health
organization
do not advocate lockdowns as the primary
means of control of this virus
the only time we believe a lockdown is
justified
is to buy you time to reorganize regroup
rebalance your resources protect your
health workers who are exhausted
but by and large we'd rather not do it
just look what's happened to the tourism
industry for example in the caribbean
or in the pacific because people aren't
taking the holidays
looks what's happened to smallholder
farmers all over the world
because their markets have got dented
look what's happening to poverty levels
it seems that
we may well have a doubling of world
poverty by next year
we may well have at least a doubling of
child malnutrition because children are
not getting
meals at school and their parents in
poor families are not able to afford it
this is a
terrible ghastly global catastrophe
actually
and so we really do appeal to all world
leaders
stop using lockdown as your primary
control method
develop better systems for doing it work
together
and learn from each other but remember
lockdowns just have
one consequence that you must never ever
uh belittle
and that is making poor people an awful
lot poorer
that is dr david navarro from the world
health organization
you probably won't see that video or
hear that statement
very much around social media because
now
the social media are clamping down on
what they say is misinformation but it
has nothing to do
with the misinformation or the accurate
information about the virus
it has everything to do with politics
and this is only going to get worse
through the election the reason that we
still have lockdowns today
is because of politics you can look at
where the lockdowns are it
always tracks with people's politics the
places that the lockdowns exist
aren't doing particularly well on the
coronavirus you look at
the one of the toughest lockdowns in the
entire country was in new york new york
got hit worse
than anybody and the lockdowns didn't
seem to help actually in some cases
the lockdowns hurt there were studies
that show that this happened in italy
and in new york by the way
that by locking people inside
particularly with elderly family members
you actually were putting them in a more
dangerous position
than you otherwise would have seen we
saw this with the nursing homes in new
york in new york governor cuomo's
policies
forced people who and sent people who
were sick with the virus
into nursing homes and guess what
happened there thousands and thousands
of senior citizens died we won't be able
by the way
to have a full picture of what happened
because
cuomo is using his political apparatus
to shut down any additional studies
of what happened that's what we're
seeing i mean if you
if you log on to social media now it is
unbearable because
first of all every time you log on they
say did you vote did you register to
vote
i'm here if i'm on instagram i'm here to
see like funny pictures
if i'm on twitter i'm here to see mean
little sardonic comments i'm not there
because i need a civic education if
you're getting your civics education
from instagram
uh probably something has gone deeply
wrong in our society
but they want to do that because they
know that those users are more likely to
vote for democrats and so they're trying
to get you
to go out there and support their
candidates and they're trying to
suppress information
that counters the democratic narrative
whether it be on widespread
unsolicited mail and voting which is
unprecedented in our country
and obviously shows signs of being open
to fraud we've seen this
recently in new jersey we've seen this
in new york we've seen this
in texas so you've got you've got those
issues and then you've obviously got
coronavirus any any comments that are
contrary to the democratic narrative
even if it comes from the world health
organization
even if it comes from the cdc's website
will be suppressed which is what's
happening right now there's a funny bit
of suppression
that just went on with president trump
he's being censored again explicitly
censored
by twitter because he was describing his
experience
of the virus but it's very difficult
because if the democrats on the left
want to defer to experts on the virus
donald trump is now
one of the leading national experts on
coronavirus why is that because he had
it
now i'm not saying you always have to
trust the experts but sometimes we
should take into account
expertise like for instance expertise on
how to protect your identity online
which you can do over at lifelock very
important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet you could miss
certain identity threats by just
monitoring your credit
luckily though there's lifelock lifelock
detects a wide range of identity threats
including your social security number
for sale on the dark web
which can be a huge issue and the
the way we open ourselves up to that is
for instance and i've done this myself
so i totally admit it
when you use the same password for a lot
of different things that's now
now that you know now i know so that's a
very bad idea but a lot of people do it
that can lead to your information being
stolen and it can go out there on the
dark web where very bad people can
misuse it no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses
but you can find out if your information
is on the dark web you can do it very
easily
and my gift to you you can do it for
free get a free dark web scan at
lifelock.com
scan s-c-a-n pick the plan that's right
for you save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
knoll so
i'll make it simple you get a free scan
at lifelock.com scan
then you get 25 off with promo code
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
also by the way guys it's baseball
season the the old glory daily wire
baseball bat is back this is our limited
edition
handcrafted custom painted baseball bat
emblazoned with the daily wire logo
we first put this bat out as a numbered
edition a few months ago
sold out in 48 hours and that was when
it was available only to all access
members
now anybody can purchase inventory
however is still very limited so get
yours before they're gone you text the
keyword baseball
b-a-s-e-b-a-l-n you probably noticed
about baseball
text that to 83 400.
eight three four zero zero text baseball
to purchase your bat today and by the
way go on over we appreciate you all
subscribing to the michael noel show
youtube channel
it's great we've got an interview up
with the man the myth the legend gad
sad head on over we'll be right back
with a whole lot more
you know i'm pretty tough on the experts
i don't think that we should just be
governed by a bunch of
experts in white lab coats who aren't
particularly
educated aren't particularly wise and
don't govern our country particularly
well
however i might make an exception to my
expert rule when it coincides with
constitutional government
because our duly elected president
donald trump now happens to be
one of the nation's foremost experts on
coronavirus just by definition he had
coronavirus
he knows more about coronavirus than
most scientists in the country
and president trump is flaunting his
expertise he tweeted out over the
weekend quote
a total and complete sign off from white
house doctors yesterday that means i
can't get it
immune and can't give it very nice to
know three exclamations points
that is very nice to know twitter
censored that they said
so you see just a big warning over the
tweet then you've got to click through
if you want to try to read it
so this tweet violated the twitter rules
about spreading misleading and
potentially harmful information related
to covid19
however twitter has determined that it
may be in the public's interest for the
tweet to remain accessible
is that so twitter is that so so now the
misleading
information you're going to put that
censorship on by the way the information
about covet is changing it seems every
single day
i'll give you an example of that give
you a great example the surgeon general
of the united states tweeted out
a number of months ago stop buying masks
people
do not buy the masks the masks don't
work against coronavirus stop buying the
masks
that tweet's still up why is that tweet
up why is that tweet not being censored
that was misleading information wasn't
it or no maybe it was just
useful and convenient information that
worked for your narrative at the time
but now it doesn't really matter because
we've moved on eric swalwell the former
future president he is me and
and i am him and we are all him eric
swalwell
that was his campaign motto he said stop
buying the masks the masks don't work
why is that tweet isn't that misleading
information
well i don't know maybe that'll be
correct information again when they
change their mind on it i don't know
dr fauci said don't wear the masks that
so that was misleading information right
because we're now told you have to wear
the masks
the masks are going to protect us so why
isn't that all being why is it
why is it it's just conservatives who
get censored
almost exclusively why is it that it's
this president in particular
just days away from a presidential
election who gets censored for saying
sure
i guess he said i can't get it anymore i
wonder i suspect that if i were a
gambling man i'd say president trump
probably isn't going to get grown virus
again
in the near future just my just my hunch
and he can't give it now the doctors are
saying he's he's
not giving out the virus right the
doctors are saying that right now
they've okayed him to go to a debate so
that part is true
at least according to his doctors maybe
twitter is disputing the doctors so
twitter is a better expert now in
coronavirus than the white house doctors
twitter is a better expert than trump
himself who had the virus i don't think
so buster
i think this is just political
censorship that's what i think it is
i think this is just the left
establishing its own set of standards
and then enforcing it as it wills to
benefit the left
and conservatives are still playing this
game where we're trying to point out
hypocrisy we're trying to
trying to play by a universal standard
the left's not playing that game
that's not the game they're playing
they're playing a game of interest
i'll give you a great example of
censorship a true this is orwellian i
know that word gets overused but this is
orwellian
right now if you go to yelp.com what do
you use it for
you're in a new area you say i want i
don't know i want chinese food tonight
let's look up chinese food then you look
on yelp and you have different reviews
and you can see which
has the best chinese food
now there's a new feature on yelp which
is you'll see you know sometimes it'll
say four stars it'll maybe say three
dollar signs how expensive it is
now you can see a little exclamation
point in red that is to let you know
that the business has been accused of
racist
behavior racist behavior
what what does that mean
what you will see is a little pop-up and
says recently someone associated with
this business was accused of racist
behavior resulting in an influx of
people posting views to this page
racism is reprehensible and has no place
on yelp and we unequivocally reject
racism in any form wow how brave
unlike all those people who totally
support racism right you know racism
that
that pervasive thing that's totally real
not just
a boogeyman and a straw man that the
left uses
that the demagogues on the left use to
shut down anybody who disagrees with
them
it's like that whole thing do you
condemn white supremacy who supports who
embraces white supremacy do you know
anybody who says yeah i love white
supremacy
i'm a huge white supremacist no
it's a phantom issue when people say
black lives matter
i'm bravely courageously saying black
lives matter how many people do you know
who say yeah black lives matter they
don't matter i hate those lives
none no nobody everybody thinks black
lives matter nobody
disagrees with the statement black lives
matter but a lot of people believe that
a lot of
other people who are not as virtuous and
wonderful as themselves that a lot of
other nefarious people
they they all say black lives don't
matter same thing with racism
nobody in this country maybe a handful
of people
would call themselves racists
but they think a whole lot of other
people are racist while we understand
the desire to warn others about racist
behavior about a business
all reviews on yelp must reflect an
actual firsthand customer experience
so we've temporarily disabled the
ability to post here as we work to
investigate the content
if you you're here to leave a review
based on a first-hand experience please
check back at a later date so
what they're saying here is they're
trying to i guess
be helpful uh if we're to give them the
benefit of the debt it's to be helpful
right because they're saying
basically there's some incident at a
place and they say it's racism
often by the way these are hoaxes this
happened very famously
outside of oberlin university there was
a restaurant that was accused of racism
and they had to shut down it was a total
hoax
so that happens then people flood it who
don't know they say you're a racist
you're racist whatever
so they're saying okay we're gonna stop
that you're not allowed to do that but
the way they're gonna stop it is by
putting a big sign that says accused of
racist behavior
define racist behavior for me i'll give
you an example
uber eats during the george floyd riots
uber eats decided that they were going
to
waive the delivery fee for black owned
businesses whatever that means
define a black owned business for me
what if a black guy owns a quarter of
the business but
is that a black owned business or do you
only get to waive a quarter of the
delivery fee whatever
so they say we're gonna waive delivery
fees for black owned businesses we're
gonna charge delivery fees for white
owned businesses
so you're you're penalizing people on
the basis of their race
right he's saying we're gonna charge
more money we're gonna make it harder
for your business to operate if you're
if you have one race but not if you're
of another race which is the definition
of racism
so is uber eats gonna get a racism
warning on yelp probably not probably
not
what about uh businesses who
buy into the blm lie that
all white people are racist because we
live in a white supremacist country
that's a racist statement are those
people with the big blm sign
are they going to get the no they're not
they're not it's just
it's just a way of signaling which are
the officially approved businesses by
the liberal establishment
and which are not which are verboten and
you're not allowed to go there
there are there are parallels to other
tyrannical sort of political regimes
here
and you see it creeping slowly you kind
of see how
how this kind of mad cultural madness
can take over but that is where we're
headed
there's not a great irony there's a real
talk about an irony
maybe the most racist anti-black
racist business in the history of the
united states
is do you know planned parenthood
planned parenthood which exists
in no small part to kill black babies
and to
shrink the black population or at least
keep it from expanding too much
the founder of planned parenthood wrote
in these terms explicitly margaret
sanger
she even at one point she said she sort
of plays this off as a bit of a joke or
a bit of irony but i think there's a lot
of truth to this irony she says
we don't want word to go out that we
want to exterminate the negro population
but even if you say oh she was just she
was being ironic in that statement
read woman in the new race read her
writings on eugenics
she clearly thought there were
undesirable populations and through
abortion
and through family planning she wanted
to shrink those
populations it's a lot worse than any
business or bakery or whatever ever did
right that if you actually go out and
you say my plan is to go into black
neighborhoods
set up shop here and kill all the black
babies that's my business model that's
my actual pitch the planned parenthood
is being accused of racism
by through an internal audit here
buzzfeed news obtain this they show that
they're accused of internal racism
race-based discrimination
acts of anti-blackness whatever i have
no idea what that means but if it's
going to hit planned parenthood fine by
me
fine by i'm not going to defend planned
parenthood i'm not going to stand in the
way
there are there was this study which was
commissioned by planned parenthood
involves a dozen social justice oriented
organizations
uh this interviewed 80 current and
former black planned parenthood
employees
and say that the organization's black
employees feel that planned parenthood's
treatment of them
internally does not line up with its
social justice driven mission of course
if if
planned parenthood is mistreating black
people it lines up perfectly with their
social justice which actually means
injustice driven organization because
the organization
exists in no small part to kill black
people
do you think planned parenthood is going
to get the racism warning on yelp
i don't think it is i don't think it is
this is
pure hackery this is
pure cynicism
i'm not saying that people can't be
partisan and give more
leniency to their own side i think
that's not only to be expected in
politics but i think it's actually
a positively good thing we ought to have
some loyalty we are fighting for real
things we are not
merely umpires who care merely about
procedure
we want to affect our vision of the good
in society
but you have to acknowledge the truth
you have to be willing to say
um i'll give you an example of this
donald trump passed that get out of jail
free bill you know the first step act
the one that goes light on crime i
thought that was a bad idea and i said
it was a bad idea
i still support trump i'm still going to
vote for him but i think it's a dumb
idea and i don't think we should support
it
same thing with uh now that now trump is
going after biden
as a racist because biden was tough on
crime in the 90s for a little bit
i think that's a bad idea i'm not i'm
not willing to go on board with that
there's a difference between being a
partisan and being an outright hack
now on the left we're seeing outright
hacks and we're seeing them
at the highest levels of the new york
times and the washington post and the
obviously the biden campaign sure the
campaigns are like that we're seeing it
at the elected level
we're seeing that now in big tech
outright hacks
this is not a good situation the
washington post
has nothing on judge amy coney barrett
we're getting the barrett confirmation
hearings this week so stay tuned for
that that's going to be
quite a ride the washington post now has
no
no way to go after her not on her record
not on her career
not on her they're trying to go after
her faith that's not working very well
so what are they doing they're going
after
her kids beth reinhard at the washington
post says
two students and a teacher at a school
attended by scotus nominee amy coney
barrett's kids test positive for
coronavirus
two weeks after a super spreader white
house event for acb
parents are freaked out though no proven
link
that's what passes for journalism now i
love at the end go no
no proven link oh so you're just
spreading baseless rumors because a
couple students
and a teacher at a school that the
judicial nominees
kids go to got the virus that has
already
infected 10 of the world population
according to the who
it's so contagious that we shut down the
global economy it's affected 10
of earth already in just nine months of
existence
but you're saying yeah but i don't know
maybe it was her kids or something and i
don't know what that means but she's bad
huh
she's really bad why are they doing this
because there is no popular support for
joe biden and kamala harris there's no
popular support
some people might vote for them because
i guess we have to you know it's there
we're democrats and he's the democrats
that we have to but
no one is saying that they're
enthusiastic about this biden and kamala
harris came to campaign together for the
first time on the campaign trail not
amazing it's already october and it's
the first time
they're campaigning together and there
was a local
news affiliate a local reporter there in
arizona who said okay i'm here
with biden harris nobody showed up
to the campaign event there's really not
much to see
i'll step out of the way but it's kind
of boring out here so it's not your
typical
camp presidential campaign event we
don't see
people rallying outside we don't see
signs or
really much of what's going on and i'm
told by one of the biden staffers
local staffers is that they kind of kept
the details about the visit
as far as the timing and the exact
locations
and pretty much all the people that we
saw enter into the parking lot
about 45 minutes ago were
with the biden harris campaign and the
pool reporter so you would expect to see
i mean
this is a pretty big event for the two
of them to be campaigning together for
the first time
since the democratic national convention
here in arizona
we've established our state has
established itself
as a battleground state and so this is
technically a big event but not
a lot of fanfare not a lot of fanfare
because nobody cares about these people
and so
what has to happen the liberal
establishment which controls every
institution just about is going to have
to do everything they can
to put the thumb on the scale for biden
harris they're going to do that in big
tech
with bogus censorship they're going to
do that
in the mainstream media obviously they
were doing it already but they've turned
it up to 11.
they're going to try to do that as a
matter of the bureaucracy and
and how our political process plays out
they're going to do this in the
presidential debates we have a
bipartisan commission
bs we only have left-wing moderators
we've only ever had
left-wing moderators at these
presidential debates and now the
moderator
from for this next debate which is
mercifully canceled
is a former biden employee who
was seen talking to this this anti-trump
person
scaramucci who got fired by trump and
now he's really upset
so and by the way he could have just
said yeah i was talking anti-trump
people i was trying to pro
trump people too to get a sense of the
debate but he couldn't do that because
he's not talking to pro-trump people
he's only talking to anti-trump people
what does he say he uses that age-old
excuse i was hacked
i was hacked we've all been hacked there
are a lot of hacks going around the
hackery is only going to keep up
through november and what i would what i
would suggest
in the meantime is regardless of the
partisanship if you can find
a somewhat straight shooter on the left
good luck but if you can find it fine
listen to that
if you find them on the right listen
listen to the ones on the right
but don't listen to the hacks i mean the
hacks of both sides are going to
wreck this political process because
we're not even talking about logic
then we're not even talking about having
a real conversation a real robust debate
over serious issues and there are
serious issues at stake
all they're going to be saying is words
words words hot air coming out of their
mouths
redefining words into nothingness hacks
all around let's hope that they don't
end up hacking this election
and and taking that that a bad political
situation
and totally turning it into rubble we've
still
we've still got a fighting chance but
the the the
deck is stacked against us that's our
show i'm michael knows this the michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses
are life family faith
those are fundamental and that's what
this show is about i hope you'll
give it a listen